so so comrades welcome to lecture what
I'm going to do now we're going to begin
with an experiment to illustrate this
point that the oxygen molecule o2 has
unpaired electrons we're outside just to
show you the reactivity of this lovely
Sofia liquid oxygen so you can see
wonderful liquid oxygen nice blue color
so on the over here on the table we've
got a tin tray which we're going to use
to to contain the experiment that I'm
going to show you next so we've got our
favorite liquid oxygen there strongly
oxidizing very very reactive and here
I've got some cotton wall so this is the
same stuff that we used to like take
makeup off perhaps our partners or our
girlfriends or our wives and it's the
same stuff that we used to wipe our
baby's bums oxygen is an interesting
element because it exists in two forms
the tall form which we breathed all the
time is o two two oxygen atoms joined
together and there's another form called
ozone in which has three atoms arranged
like a letter V or letter V this way up
oxygen has unpaired electrons within the
molecular orbitals in atomic orbitals
around the structure and these unpaired
electrons give rise to color and that
color is blue so blue is often perceived
to be the color of solvated or unpaired
electrons and you can see here the
lovely blue color now lots of chemists
are really scared when they see the blue
of liquid oxygen because liquid oxygen
is very very reactive generally you only
make liquid oxygen by mistake not like
today when we're making some on purpose
and if you've made it in by mistake in
an uncontrolled way where there might be
organic molecules perhaps simple organic
chemicals like hydrocarbons grease or
perhaps a highly elaborate compound then
they tend to detonate and they tend to
cause very energetic experiments so you
know it's really fluffy it's not very
reactive doesn't really burn cinders
make much smolder but here we go we're
going to pop it in the tree so we begin
with Neil's very high-tech piece of
equipment
which is a test tube on a piece of
string what we're going to do is to put
some liquid nitrogen in here you can see
liquid nitrogen well you may not see is
colorless okay so this is liquid
nitrogen and what I hope you can see is
that this magnet which is a pretty good
magnet let me just show you here with my
keys that they stick pretty strongly to
the magnet that the magnet has
absolutely no effect at all on the
liquid nitrogen I can pull the magnet
and nothing happens and then we're going
to fill up all of the void space or all
of the space between the cop the cop the
cotton particles with oxygen so you
might want to stand back after this bit
Brady so here we go is our liquid oxygen
going to come in and zoom in onto me
okay
so here you can see the lovely blue
liquid oxygen color going into there to
the cotton wall particles let's try the
same thing with liquid oxygen so careful
of my shoes
so here we have a match on a stick and I
think you can see it's probably a light
so we have our fire we have our oxygen
and we have our fuel now let's see what
happens we put them all together the
liquid oxygen it's a very nice blue
color today so now let's try here's the
magnet again and if I take the liquid
oxygen you can see I can pull it right
up here because what it's not as
magnetic as my keys but you can see
there's a really big difference it
sticks to the magnet so you can see it
really is magnetic you ready okay whoo
and there she blows
and ozone is much more reactive than
oxygen so near the Earth's surface where
we you and I are at the moment
ozone is really quite dangerous because
if you breathe it in it can start
reacting with the any sort of molecule
that has bonds between carbon but in the
upper atmosphere ozone is extremely
important because it absorbs ultraviolet
light that comes from the Sun and stops
this ultraviolet light attacking the
molecules in biological species on the
surface if it wasn't for the ozone in
the upper atmosphere all of us would be
if not dead certainly very much less
comfortable than we are at the moment so
Neil is now collecting up a piece of
that a piece of tube to the oxygen
cylinder and he's going to fill up this
gas jar with oxygen and we're going to
do a really classic experiment the one
that everyone learns at school a test
for oxygen which is to relight a glowing
splint so we have a traditional gas jar
full of oxygen so here you can see we're
burning a splint okay so this is the the
wood burning in excess oxygen around us
okay so now what we're going to do is
we're going to take the splint out so
that is just glowing so if I blow on the
splint you can see it gets brighter now
we're going to try and relight that
splint
by putting it into a very oxygen-rich
atmosphere so we'll move over to the jar
and we'll put in our glowing splint and
you can see the flame comes back to life
so that's a test that everyone learns
for an oxygen-rich environment happens
what may go well the increased oxygen
content called concentration reignites
and re initiates that oxidation of the
of the wood or the burning of the wood
so we'll do that again so there we go
flame again